hey everyone it's Michael wos and
welcome to the orderflows market
analysis for uh Tuesday July 25th
2017 uh kind of a quiet day uh was first
day of the fomc meeting so it's kind of
exped to be quiet tomorrow uh things
should pick up as you know people get a
better idea of what the FED intends to
do uh before we get started brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
Contract or make any other type of
investment decision Futures training
contains substantial risk is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results so the
tools I Ed in this presentation are the
order flows Trader and the Delta scalper
we recently uh re-released it uh say
re-released it but uh we came out with a
upgraded version of the Delta scalper
and if you're interested in it and you
are already a user of the Delta scalper
send me an email to don't send it to
Mike at orderflow send it to upgrade at
Deltas scaler.com
that and then I can we can reply to you
to get you the upgraded version of the
delt scalper if you're already using it
okay if not uh go to
www.d Deltas scaler.com
to learn more about it but anyway um
let's uh let's jump into the markets
today okay so the First Market we'll
talk about today is the British pound um
now now this is just the normal go2
trade I talk about every single day in
in these uh presentations is you have
the Divergence and you got the ratio
afterwards so you're rallying up and you
got the bearish Divergence you got the
bearish ratio and the market sells off
over the next three bars before you come
down here you got the Delta scalper
giving a buy which just sort of went
sideways on you over the next uh four
bars before failing and making new lows
now the other interesting thing about
this high is look at this okay look at
these Deltas small Deltas 38 36 22 100
15 2 1155 then we make this move up here
uh - 94 new high - 108 new high- 90 new
High new high- 435 so you got your
strongest negative Delta at the high of
the day that's a very bearish sign um
why do you have a high why do you have
Market rallying on negative Delta you
know people say how can that be you know
you're rallying you should be having net
positive Delta but Delta Works in two
ways one you know it's the net what it
is is is the difference between the net
aggressive buying and net aggressive
selling and when you move in higher and
you got negative Delta what it's telling
you this is what you know this is the
beauty of order flows the market is
telling you that you have supportive
buying on this way up not necessarily
aggressive buying right you you're not
you're going higher because people are
buying yes but what you have also is
strong supportive buying passive buying
here 122 if you didn't you know if this
was a smaller number if this was 30
you'd have maybe a small positive Delta
or a small negative Delta it could go
either way here you got 216 if this was
100 you'd have a positive Delta here
minus 90 yeah you have aggressive buying
up here to top of this bar 200 100 122
but look at this supportive buying here
158 160 uh 468 141 you know if this was
268 you'd have a strong positive Delta
it' be
290 but it's minus 90 why because you
have supportive Bine here you had people
selling into this bid you had someone
there bidding right at this level but
you and you had sellers selling into it
trying to call this the high but they
couldn't because the buyers were still
there the buyers were here the buyers
are here on this move up even here look
at this 500 497 800 even above it 474
but look at this grouping of three right
here you got strong negative Delta 435
so you're coming up here to this High
you still got this strong supportive
buying yes people are selling into it
but it's still there supporting the
market okay you finally make this new
high start coming down the suppor of
buying is you know for whatever is I'll
say it's overrun but you know we get
past it it's no longer there and the
selling is taken over now and we make
this move lower so you know that's how
you can make a high on negative Delta
now now just really quick um I'll pull
in this chart of the Delta scalper since
you know Delta scalper has been the Hot
Topic
recently uh this is just a bar chart I'm
just showing you on the bar chart to
make it easier for you just to see I
could show you on the orderflow chart
but um I just want to show you so 5 in
the morning you got Delta scalper giving
you a buy 130 um we'll call it 40 area
what does it do it Rally's all the way
up here this is that high and I was just
talking about up to you know
131 that that's the move you know if you
could just get one move a day
great here's this is uh the one that
failed this one failed here so you got
basically you had what do you have you
have three trades today and two losers
One
winner you know can you can you accept
these two little losers here I mean
what's your risk your risk is basically
one bar here and then you get the winner
here which is you know 10 bars now not
every trade is going to be you know a 10
to1 risk reward ratio but you know this
is what looking for with you know with
the Delta
scalper okay so this is a Japanese and
15minute chart on the footprints and
again I'm not a big advocate of trading
you know 15minute charts with Footprints
however the information that you're
looking at is still valid right I mean
you're still still analyzing Delta the
same way you would I mean Delta is you
know is a is a piece of the order flow
right when I when I say I don't like
looking at footprint charts for
50-minute charts because I like ratios
right right I like divergences and you
tend not to get you know since it's just
so much time and so much volume in a bar
um you know that aspect of order
flow on a 15-minute chart on a 30-
minute chart isn't uh you know isn't
going to be very useful but you when
you're looking at Delta which is again
the net difference of buyer aggressive
buyers and aggressive sellers you know
it's very revealing you know that and
that's why I like the Delta scalp that's
why I develop tools like the Delta
scalper to help me you know on charts
that you know my traditional type of
orderflow analysis you know isn't very
powerful now people say well if it
doesn't work on a 15-minute chart what
good is it well you know
orderflow think about what orderflow is
right it's the orders coming into the
market and honestly looking at a
15minute chart you know if a bar forms
every 15 minutes and if you if you're
waiting for the bar to form you know the
flow that happened 14 minutes ago is
probably can be very important but
you're missing it because you know
you're Trading a long-term chart you're
waiting for the bar to close that's why
I prefer to trade orderflow on shorter
term charts you know four range charts I
hate to say minute charts but I I do
look at minute charts there are certain
things I do look for minute
charts but you know there's you know
really the reality of it is you know if
if you're trading the ticker tape
honestly you know that's what orderflow
is trading a 15-minute chart is like
trading with delayed quotes I mean
that's my opinion you know you could
throw stones at me for you know what you
will but honestly orderflow is best used
best applied with um a shorter term
chart not a 15minute chart not a
30-minute chart however there are pieces
of orderflow point of control um Delta
that you know can be very revealing on
longer term charge I mean the same
Concepts will still apply but you know
for me for my type of orderflow analysis
I prefer shorter term charts so here's
Delta scal gives a buy next bar up big
bar up another bar highs right off the
high Delta scalper gives a sell you know
what is that 90 uh
90 9036 area I don't know
9038 and it just drops I mean this is at
2 in the morning people say oh it's 2 in
the morning not a lot of volume um 5: in
the morning you get the the scalper buy
here it goes up a little bit not much
comes down you know probably would have
stopped you out if you're still in that
position then here you got Delta scalper
giving you a nice sell next bar big down
bar from 90 even
down to 9084 even goes lower over the
next bar gets down here down to 8980
where you got Delta scalper buy that
failed another Delta scalper this is 1
in the afternoon Delta scalper sell
right before this big move down here
from you know this one bar here from uh
76 down to 60 so you know can order flow
be used on longer term charts 15minute
charts yes it can do the way I trade
with the order flow
um you know does the way I trade with
orderflow can be that be applied to a
15-minute chart you know certain tools
can but you know not everything you know
I mean if you're looking at order flow
on a one minute chart you or you know a
third I'll say a 30 second chart but you
know a four range chart you know you're
going to have to look at it differently
if you're trading you know a 15minute
chart a 30- minute chart because you
know what you're looking for is changes
in the order flow okay so this is the E
mini this is the four range chart this
morning and you know it it was basically
straight up from the European session uh
you know we came
in here at 1:00 a.m. basically you've
got
2468 and
34s 2466 in three so a three-point range
so even though you have something like a
ratio Divergence you know don't don't
get too excited with any sort of signal
when you're trading in such a such a
tight range you know you will get
signals but again You Know It wait for
the market to be moving uh before taking
trades you know if you're trading in a
three-point range in the S&P that's
nothing um you know finally you got this
breakout here 400 a.m you got a ratio
and Divergence yeah you know it it's you
know at this point you know you're
trading 60 69 and 3/4
so you know it's it's a slightly bigger
range you know can you take it yeah you
can make the argument that you could you
know but um again it's still in a tight
range you let let the market have some
expansion before you start trading it
you know I mean what's the point of
trading the market with such a tight
range that it's just contained you know
yeah you can sell off from your high to
your low but it'll be you know two
points or you know and you'd be lucky to
get a point out of that move but anyway
you know yeah if you took it you got
stopped out but look what happens in the
next bar you got three imbalances not
stacked imbalance we get so used to
looking for stacked imbalances that
sometimes we just Overlook bars with
multiple imbalances even though they're
just as important then you're breaking
out to the new highs with a stacked
imbalance which is bullish as well so
you know you got almost a stacked in
Balance here another stacked in Balance
here as you're going into new highs hey
you know you at this point you should
realize hey you got aggressive buying
coming in here okay so you make new
highs make new highs there's no reason
to be getting short anywhere you know
selling it on this move you come up here
you got a ratio and
Divergence now you know now I'm fine you
know I'm thinking hey I could sell this
thing the only thing that's holding me
back is it's 754 you know it's 30
minutes before the cash open I know once
the cash open everything is going to
change but anyway there's you know if
you got short there I thought about it
it came right back up made a new high
okay yeah it would have been stopped out
what a point okay fair enough you know
that that's what trading is you got to
make decisions you got to take trades
you got to take losses you know if you
don't take your losses then uh sorry you
don't take trades that that lose then
you know you're not a real Trader but
then you get up here to this High new
high right on the cash open Divergence
almost a ratio it's 74 but you don't
have the ratio there but the next bar
you've got the ratio so you got the
ratio and Divergence again I talk about
this every day you know these things
appear almost daily sometimes two or
three times a day um this is very
bearish and what happens the market
sells off from this uh 76 76 and a half
area down to this area around 74 where
it just sort of goes sideways 74 75 so
you know you got got a little bit of a
move it wasn't the greatest move okay
it's fed day um so you got about a
two-point move there now again you know
you got in this bar here if you're not
convinced that you know hey we're going
to come off from this high what do you
got you got three imbalances in the bar
okay um eventually you go down a little
bit lower down to 72 and a half Delta
scalper gives this buy here now at this
low you get what do you have down here
you got point of control right at the
low bullish sign you've got a ratio
bonds low indicating some stopping
volume also a bullish sign next bar you
got the Delta scalper giv a buy so you
got another bullish sign Delta's
expanding 6 2 917 2800 and what happens
is you make a move back up towards the
highs you don't take out the high
immediately or anything like that but
you just started rallying over the next
one two three bars so again it's a move
from you know 74 back up to 76 76 and a
half two-point
move then eventually you make these new
highs up here 1110 what do you got
you've got boom you've got Divergence
you got the negative Delta on the high
you've got ratio bounds low indicating
stopping bom so you got your Divergence
and your ratio what happens the market
starts working its way back down notice
to where you pull back when you get up
to that high you pull back right up to
that point of control this point of
control is your
resistance and then you come off from 78
down to 76 it's another two points Delta
scalper gave you a buy here at 152 in
the afternoon didn't work just yeah it
went up with the next bar then failed
and and sold off um stopped you out
Delta scalper you know coming into this
close although at this point you know
you one one minute ahead of the cash
close you know the thing about the cash
close it's the time of the day that's
going to have the most volume So you
you're going to get surges in Delta one
way or the other
um I personally had steer clear of
trading around the cash close just
because of the sheer amount of volume
coming in you may get some I don't want
to say false readings but you know
readings just due to the immense amount
of flow coming in you know because all
the index funds are based in you know
their orders on the cash
close all right so uh you know today in
the room I had a question about you know
how can you spot Trend days because you
know on Trend days you tend to get run
over you know on Trend days there's two
problems one is getting run over right
you take a position then you get run
over and two is you on a trend day if
you didn't identify it you get out too
soon so it's more than one issue on on
Trend days yeah one you're going to get
stopped out a lot if you know you're
trying to Buck the trend and two is um
you know unless you have a way to
recognize that you're in a trend day you
know how can you
maximize the trend you know trend is
your friend until it stops right but you
know sometimes people don't realize that
you're in a you know in a major Trend or
there's a strong Trend uh developing
that you know the market is going to
keep going in that direction and you
know and they get out a little bit early
and you know and as as a Trader
sometimes you kick yourself right they
say oh you I got out too early if only
if only I I let it you know last you
know another two minutes you know
there's times where I I take profit and
then boom literally 10 seconds later the
market explodes in my direction so you
know I get out with you know three ticks
four ticks you know five ticks in the
bonds and then okay I'm there you know
patting myself on the back then I look
at the screen and then the market just
screams up another 10 ticks almost
immediately you know it's it I don't say
it's disheartening you know it's one of
those things like oh if if only but you
know honestly you know if you stick to
your trading plan you know and that's
what your target is stick with it you
know don't don't uh beat yourself over
over that you know I mean I knew guys
that you know were trading crude
oil you know the guy runs his own fund
and you know had all these options on
when crude oil was trading you know over
100 bucks and you know he was looking
for a move below 100 bucks and massive
options positions on and the guy you
know he he closed out his position you
know he made like 300 million bucks or
something like that but you know when
all of a sudden all the dust settled
down he's like looking at it he says
man if if I just held on to it I
could could have made over a billion
dollars but you know it's nice to look
back and say oh yeah look at this chart
I could have made that but honestly you
know if you have your your trading plan
written out you know what your profit
targets are you you shouldn't feel bad
that you got out early although it does
suck I'll be I'll be the first to admit
you know it does suck there's times
where I do get out early and then you I
just didn't feel right you know in the
trade so I got out and then
literally almost immediately the market
makes its move that I was waiting for
but you know one of the ways I like to
look for a market that's trending
obviously watch the Delta right negative
Delta overall is a sign of a of a market
moving down you know strong positive
Delta Market moving up but you know I'm
always watching these things like these
divergences you know if if I get
groupings of them that fail then you
know I have a feeling that you know
we're in a trending market right because
you get the little bit of buying coming
in you got the positive Delta but the
selling you know then watch the next bar
strong selling so you got a positive
Delta of of a th000 here you got diver
and then what happens next bar twice as
much selling 2,000 here you got another
one pop up you got a positive Delta 1300
boom um you know I would is ADD about
140% more uh selling versus the previous
bar you know so then I I watched the
next you know when we come down into low
what I'd like to see is imbalances you
know in 5 years honestly it's not easy
to get as many imbalances as as you
would in some of these other markets
just because a sheer amount of volume
but you know on normal markets like I'll
show you I'll say normal markets but
other other markets that move you know
that aren't so thick in depth of Market
you you'll tend to see imbalances you
know if it's really legitimate selling
going into lows or buying imbalances
going to into highs so that's why you
know when we came down into these lows I
was expecting the five years to make
newer lows new more new lows and we did
you know from 30 you we got into this
area down here at 30 with very strong
volume and you I was looking for this
you know see which way we going to stay
you know on which side of it and we just
sort of traded around that area for the
next hour um and then some more selling
came in and we did make a new low new
low but again you know this low there's
no reason to be buying it yeah you have
a nice strong positive
Delta didn't build on it in the next bar
small Delta actually was it looked
encouraging you had 2,000 positive Delta
but it ended up at 137 so it gave it all
back so even though it was
positive you know you had another 2,000
came in there and and sold it back down
basically so even though it's a positive
Delta it does look negative come down in
here negative Delta NE you know strong
negative Delta with the imbalances then
you get down here again which I just
finished talking about in um the British
pound in the E minis ratio I'm sorry
Divergence no ratio what do you got in
the next bar you got your ratio so
Divergence and ratio and then you know
the next three bars you make a move up
um before you start coming back down you
got got three in a row right here
actually had a three in a row here this
was kind of confusing in the in the
sense that you got you know three in a
row bullish three in a row bearish but
you know what can you do I mean this
one's set up the way you like I don't
like when you get
a ratio you know at the at the you at
the turn you know you got ratio ratio
ratio then you got the bearish ratio I
don't like that I'd prefer just a normal
um normal order flow and then it just
sort of fell out and came down then you
got another three in a row which didn't
work out down here 2:00 again is is the
cash Clos in the bonds you got a stacked
imbalance off the low you got the Delta
scalper you got a ratio this one again
you know honestly you shouldn't be
trading bonds after 2:00 I hate to say
you shouldn't be but um you know that's
when essentially the cash session
closes but again you had you taken this
yeah you would have been stopped out you
know but you had a nice little winner
here in uh earlier you know during the
normal session
okay just really quick um this is soy
meal not a lot of people trade the eggs
you know honestly most people trade the
E crude and currencies or bonds but you
know eggs are are great markets they
follow orderflow really well um you know
soy meal is a contract that's pretty um
near to my heart but again you know the
same things apply now look at this move
down here okay so here this bar strong
negative Delta 574
36018 selling is strong on the way down
but you know it's kind of weakening
right the Delta even though you got a
stacked in Balance here you know it's
strong here
574 then it's weakening it's lightening
up 360 then it's very weak 18 it's kind
of neutral down here it's positive 75 so
it's changed right you got a couple
things going on you got the Delta
scalper one you got a Divergence because
you got positive Delta and you got a
ratio and you know what happens over the
next couple bars the next bar just comes
right down on you you test the low you
get within a tick of the low here then
you shoot back up test the low here
again and then you shoot back up now for
those that aren interest uh familiar
with soy meal it's uh $10 a tick so you
know three you know this is what 328 so
move from 328 to 329 is 100
bucks you know so here you got you're
risking getting along at 328 your stops
down here at 327 so you're risking um 10
ticks you know probably would have been
able to squeeze out only about 10 ticks
yeah it got up to 329.50 but you know
honestly went I just would have been
happy to get out up here you know Break
Even to you know maybe five ticks but
again it's the same thing you know yeah
it's not always the big monster move up
but sometimes it's just like that I mean
you can only trade what the Market's
going to give you honestly once you
start testing the lows twice that's
probably not a very good sign but um you
know it's more of a market going
sideways but you know you could have got
something out of it you could have got
something out of it but you're looking
at the same things here right you're
looking at the ratio and Divergence
obviously Delta scalper but the same the
same things apply to whether you're
looking at grains or interest rates or
crude oil or stock indexes okay so next
up I'll talk about crude oil since uh
we're talking about some commodity
contracts and it really wasn't much in
the crude oil uh is terms of order flow
on a on a pure order flow sense I mean
yeah I can talk about a few things but
keep it simple I'll talk about the Delta
scalper here so here at uh 3:49 in the
morning you know if you're awake you
alerted to something
you know 4660 all the way up to new
highs here um higher higher higher and
just you know just makes This brilliant
move up to all the way up to you know
the high here at 700 in the
morning you know there there's no reason
to be getting short here yeah you have a
Divergence here but that's it um then
you get to this High you got a
Divergence again um here you got Delta
scalper giv a cell what happens the
market just goes sideways comes off a
little bit and then makes another run up
um but really the big move I mean
there's no reason to be really getting
short up
here you I mean the big move started
early in the crude this
morning you you get up to this High here
yeah you got point of control up near
the top but you know again that that
that by itself is not a reason but
you're not really getting any strong
reasons I mean people say well you got
Divergence Market came off okay fair
enough um you know personally me
personally I like to get a little bit
more than just a
Divergence um you know then here here
this is already 3:30 in the afternoon so
even though you had a big move up you
know in the crude you know the sign was
you know crude is is contract that you
know really trades around the clock and
if you're trading it during the US
session um I I didn't think there was
any strong really strong strong um
things in the
orderflow but you know sometimes that's
how it is with the market you know you
don't get what you want out of
it okay so anyway so thanks for watching
this video um I don't want to keep it
too long it's already 25 minutes uh to
learn more about orderflow visit my
website order flows.com uh to learn more
about the Delta scalper I'm going to
create a separate video just on the
Delta scalper just to go over some
charts really quick again I want to keep
it separate than this one I don't want
to keep this one running too long but uh
you go to Deltas scaler.com so thanks
everyone bye-bye